so for you like uh let's break that
because because you're one of the hook
guys now who would you say is like a
Mount Rushmore of the best hook men of
all time
who's the hook gods
motherhood Gods Nate Dogg Nate Dogg is I
feel like Undisputed top number one slot
right yeah
I'm gonna go to um
a little Chris Brown
and of course I'm gonna go to Ty Dollar
shout out to Ty
and then I'm gonna go to at the tie
I'm gonna go to Sanford
oh yeah like not even though he did a
lot of hooks but but the ones he did did
[__] everybody up
tip on them right now like I think back
to uh the video of like when Walo met
him and like yeah
and I just remember being like damn I
really need to dive into this guy's
[__] catalog if he's making grown man
cry out here and making real music bro
like
a lot of [__] be overshadowed but
the music the real music to be put in
the back a lot nowadays but when you tap
in like a [__] like Sanford that [__]
special bro I was gonna say like uh
what what was it like growing up in
Philly for you because we kind of hear
so much you know my own co-host DJ
damages from Philly
and he would always tell me like about
North Philly and places like Chester
Pennsylvania and just like yeah like
Phillies like that just that area in
general wild place and there's a lot of
videos that have been going viral
recently of like
because at fentanosh it's really bad
yeah right you've probably seen the
videos of people like slumped out like
looking like zombies all over the street
and [__] out there yeah that's right
that's like near where I'm from a little
bit by the way also Happening Here in LA
but you know he
um but what was it like for you growing
up in Philly I mean obviously you you
were going to church and you know I'm
sure you were you had a a great
childhood but like was it was it I mean
easier or hard for you to deal with like
kind of
staying out of that [__] you know church
was in the trenches yeah right my pop
church was in the trenches bro so it was
like it's not like I had an easy
childhood like [__] as soon as you step
out of church it might be a shoot up
that's what I mean but you were able to
kind of keep it's kind of like you gotta
like
it's a rough neighborhood bro it's easy
to like fall into the like it's easy to
break step into that lifestyle right
and it's like you really just gotta stay
out the way mm-hmm like
just stay out the way bro like because
it'll be like you'd be in the way not
even on some dumb [__] you just be in
the way some crazy because where you're
at yeah just like you're at the wrong
place at the right time so what I will
say like I was always focused on music
like everybody knew me I asked fried I
want some music [__] like you know what
I'm saying like I used to engineer
[__] in Philly producer [__] like on
some studio [__] yeah I'm saying so
it was just like I was always on some
music [__] and out the way forever so
it's definitely like a rough City though
but you really gotta like just you gotta
be focused you gotta be focused for sure
so you don't get fall into you know yeah
um what do you how do you feel about the
other Trend that's happening in Philly
right now if you think a guy's like too
rare and just like the dance [__] is
going crazy like they have it anyway bro
they're having a way yeah they having
their way like it's beautiful bro to see
who's a good kid you guys just signed
I'm just like
it's like everybody's kind of doing
their own version of the Philly thing
everybody having fun bro like they
brought it like a a fun vibe fun energy
that was missing and that's why I like
afrobeat doing what he's doing like you
be in the club
all these songs about killing and [__]
all this afro [__] come on [__] just
want to have fun and dance bro like I
feel that's why afrobe doing so good and
even the uh [__] from Philly like they
bringing like Good Vibes back I mean I'm
thinking like even like obviously uzi's
from Philly right so Uzi Like Doing Just
Wanna Rock
looks like the biggest song in the club
for like a year yeah it's like just this
fun song like
fun music bro and them regular [__]
too From The Trenches too so like don't
get it like you know what I'm saying
like them they just decide yeah they
focusing on the right [__] like we don't
gotta be on those Street [__] making
songs about violence and all that ain't
just having fun bro did you ever like uh
tap in with like uh like obviously prior
to your generation but did you ever dive
into any of the roots of music back from
back in the day
uh a little bit like black thought's one
of the greatest rappers that ever walk
on the planet you know I wasn't really
on that but I wasn't on that though but
I'm familiar like I know they're Legends
you got a [__] Quest love haven't
played drums on a song or something I
know Clint slow you know he's feeling
the drums just like yo I'd be an honor
man come and play drums on this you know
just for Philly yeah for sure but I
wasn't really on them early like I mean
you weren't on them early because you
also weren't alive exactly because being
on them early would have been you were
listening to them because I think their
first album was like 92. huh
yeah I was knowing them a lot of and
that album isn't even on Spotify you got
to buy it like on a real the real jump
yeah it's like yeah and then you know
Scott Storage yeah Fogel store he was in
the roots for real that's crazy I knew
that somebody told me that that's what
started in the roots yeah Legend you got
to get with storage man have you gotten
in with them yet no not yet he's a
legend though let him tell you some
stories now I know he got some crazy
asses the craziest ever
any girl that you think of when I say
this to you right now that pops in your
head
he is true he [__] everybody first so
whatever girls just popped up in your
head yep then everybody everybody
we gotta sit down with skorts gotta go
out to Miami when I heard he went stupid
when he was up and then he went down but
he's back up you back up right now
though yeah he got through it I heard
that story like he used to snack the
amount of money Scott Storage was
spending on just like everything was
just in I mean Jesus Christ God bless
that guy I'm just a legend his cousin
Mark [__] with squished we'd be having a
argument like who better Timbo or Scorch
I'll be going with Timbo
I think it's like Timberland's like top
three ever so his range is insane yeah
Bubba Sparks he could do it I mean he
could do it Nelly Furtado like that's
why he my favorite yeah the the range of
uh of him is insane how you have you
heard anybody try to make an AI version
of yourself yet
no I'm waiting it's gonna happen yeah
I'm wet I want to hear it though like
yeah like can AI nail your your tone you
know
I mean ain't nothing some others crazy
[__] they are Ellen Rihanna Kanye the
Rihanna Tim's remix that [__] crazy it's
a fire yeah
I seen some other [__] it was a
I think it was Kanye and Franco Kanye
singer Frank Ocean joke no Kanye's under
Justin Bieber
yeah that [__] was crazy though
yeah it's kind of crazy the AI thing is
getting a little it's getting a little
sketch I hope they I hope they shut that
[__] down though they're not going to
the labels are going to start [__]
doing the same [__] the actors are doing
you see why the actors are on strike
yeah cause they're trying to slide in a
little artificial intelligence into the
movies yeah so like extras like they
want the extras to be like AI like they
want to be able to scan like an actor
and then use their artificial likeliness
let's go it's coming bruh [__] hang out
man yeah
made a song like Drake featuring The
Weekend that [__] hit like a million the
first time oh yeah yeah that's this was
like yeah this was like what maybe like
six months ago seven months yeah it was
recent and that [__] that [__] went
viral they like this [__] hard because
it's like also not a bad idea if you're
a writer I wonder if it's a terrible
idea to like writers on there right now
right is doing all AI [__] because like
this is what this is like let me send
this out so like my thing is is if
you're a writer and you write a song for
Drake do you send the AI Drake version
to his team so he'd be like look this is
how he would sound I've seen some [__]
like I don't like with some Rider they
got some [__] I can imagine man like
they're not even writing any boys